the kingdom may be united but its
leaders are not as the four nations
diverge on their covered response there
will be no further measures uh before
the new year we won't be taking any
further measures of course people should
remain cautious as we approach new year
celebrations and you know take a lateral
flow test that makes sense celebrate
outside if you can have some ventilation
indoors if you can please remain
cautious and when we get into the new
year of course we will see then whether
we do need to take any further measures
but nothing more until then at least
boosters are part of the reason boris
johnson has held his nerve
covered cases in england may have
reached a record high but
hospitalizations have not although they
are at their highest level in england
since last march we're just not seeing
those numbers at this point that we saw
in january 2021 but the view is very
clear it's still too early to tell about
whether we are going to see larger
numbers of older people coming in
needing that kind of care as omicron
reaches the older population and in
particular as all of this
intergenerational mixing that we've been
doing over the last few days works
through
hospitality venues face restrictions in
scotland wales and northern ireland
including the closure of nightclubs but
they will remain open including on new
year's eve in england all this has been
welcomed by conservative mps who were
rebelling just a fortnight ago this is
excellent news for the country it's
excellent news for the hospitality
industry that people can go out and
enjoy new year
and also the underlying message is that
the data that the prime minister and the
health secretary receiving from the
scientists supports what we suspected
that omicron variant is
mild for the vast majority of cases it's
leading to fewer hospitalizations
far less serious
illness and fewer deaths
boris johnson has been criticized
throughout this pandemic for moving too
slowly this time however his pace may
have been perfect but it is a big gamble
for a man who has taken a lot of bold
chances throughout his political career
and we will know within days whether
this call was right and responsible
or reckless
for now a decision has been deferred but
with the numbers still high it has not
disappeared